ich glaube es kann da ja keiner ohne
gemischte gefühle hinschauen ich sehe
die die frauen mit zum teil mehreren
kindern auf dem arm eindeutig in einer
notsituation und da möchte man sagen
kommt wir helfen euch wir helfen euch
dann sehe ich diese steinzeit männer mit
ihren maschinengewehren des einzigen
modernen ist es die sind die waffen
sozusagen das denken ist steinzeitlich
das verhalten des steinzeitlich alles
was sie tun ist menschenverachtend und
irgendwie ist man hin und her gerissen
aber ich glaube dass jetzt aus der sicht
deutschlands mit diesen gedanken
2015 soll sich nicht wiederholen das ist
ja der satz den die bundeskanzler
ausgesprochen hat den kanzlerkandidaten
laschet wiederholt hat der einst es so
etwas ist wie ausgesprochene staatsräson
der muss dann auch was bedeuten und da
fallen mir zwei dinge auf die gefahr ist
so groß den falschen zu vertrauen
menschen die uns wieder ausnutzen wollen
die unser sozialsystem ausnutzen wollen
die vielleicht sogar schlimme taten im
kopf haben und vorbereiten und dann
ausüben in unserem land denen zu
vertrauen ist ganz gefährlich ich rate
bei der migrationspolitik zu einer
politik des gesunden misstrauen jeder
von uns hat doch so ein gesundes
misstrauen wenn er mit etwas
konfrontiert was er nicht kennt hat man
so eine leichte reserviertheit die
politik 2015 war aber eine politik des
ungesunden vertrauens wir haben einfach
jedem vertraut dass er schon hilfe
braucht und auf keinen fall ein böser
mensch ist und jetzt bin ich sozusagen
bei einem meiner sache die mich wirklich
in der zweiten woche nach kabul
flughafen sozusagen wirklich bewegt und
das sind wer sind eigentlich diese
ortskräfte also klar es sind erst sehr
wenige in den fliegern gewesen es sollen
aber sehr viele kommen fallen zahlen des
außenministers von 70.000 menschen aber
wer sind die und jetzt greift wieder
dieses ungesunde vertrauen mein wort
dafür wären naivität dieser gedanke alle
ortskräfte sind gute menschen weil die
haben uns ja geholfen ist natürlich
grenzenlos naiv das sind gute menschen
dabei gewesen die demokratie wollen
freiheit wollen gleiche rechte für
männer und frauen wollen aber das sind
natürlich auch ganz ganz viele dabei die
das alles nicht wollen weil sie kinder
ihr kultur ihrer tradition sind das kann
man ihnen noch nicht mal zum vorwurf
machen es gibt berichte von bundeswehr
offizieren die sagen da sind auch leute
ortskräfte gewesen die haben uns
bespitzelt haben verraten was in unserem
leben den taliban verraten was in
unserem lager los war da sind auch leute
gewesen wir haben uns erpresst und
wollten immer mehr geld die haben also
quasi die bundeswehr abgezockt auch das
sind ortskräfte und die lassen wir nun
auch in unser land das finde ich schon
sehr sehr problematisch
[Musik]